[Music]
the cause of all the catastrophes we are
seeing today is overpopulation we were
proud to unveil the only practical
remedy to humanity's greatest problem
are you ready
doctor yes I'm ready
Wow that is wildin it's just while
that's Dave Dave Johnson everybody and
Carol he never struck me as the kind of
guy who'd go get small downsizing takes
a pressure right off
plus you're really making a difference
you mean all that crap about saving the
planet yeah downsizing is about saving
yourself we live like kings got best
houses best restaurants Cheesecake
Factory got three of them in leisure
laying your $52,000 translates to 12.5
million dollars to live on what life Wow
do you understand that you will undergo
the permanent and irreversible medical
procedure commonly known as downsizing
and that your bodies will be
approximately point zero three six four
percent of their current mass and volume
nervous little Missy on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the small world is filled with things to
see
[Music]
sometimes you think we're in the normal
world and if something happens oh my god
and you realize we're not
[Music]